now i don't usually do reacts and stuff
like that i
you know i feel like it can it can get a
little bit
like you know i just feel like it's how
do i phrase it
it doesn't take much work for me and i
know that's not what people come for but
charlie one of charlie's funniest videos
and i've always found this to be one of
his funniest videos
is okay we have to watch this i mean
we'll do the speedrun i promise
afterward
but i i have to show you this video
because it's it's hilario if anybody
hasn't seen it it's actually very very
funny
and it's making fun of um
the sort of day in the life of ceo kind
of videos
um and charlie does it like nobody else
like he's
so funny it's crazy
[Music]
today i want to talk about a popular
trend on youtube i've actually touched
on it before
it's those morning routine videos from
rich people that are supposed to be like
almost motivational but usually are just
used as a vessel to promote their newest
product line that's coming out
so i want to talk about one in
particular here that i think serves as a
good example for all of them
this is the daily routine of a 24 year
old ceo
and just in case you didn't hear me this
is a 24 year old ceo and
you best not forget this man this 24
year old ceo
is ceo of five companies and out of the
goodness of his heart he's granting us
permission to take a sneak peek into his
day-to-day
life in his near celestial existence we
as spectators get to come in and observe
and learn from him he's allowing us
to suckle on his bosom nay he is
grabbing us
by our unworthy skulls and placing it on
his nipples to suckle
and believe it or not we are truly
blessed he's giving us a sneak preview
of his upcoming product lines
one of my favorite ideas that i've ever
heard was the thought of
doing today what others aren't willing
to do so i can do tomorrow
what they can't what meet jose
the man your girlfriend is [ __ ] in
her dreams jose is a 20
year old ceo if you can believe that and
we're about to see what it's like to go
on a date with him because this is
definitely not a
day-to-day routine because he's
shirtless half the time and it feels
like he's trying to get my dick out of
my pants
i really feel like this video should
have been what it's like to date a 24
year old ceo
and spoiler alert it looks like a
headache this man is so full of cliches
and he just comes across as super
disingenuous especially when the
majority of this is just centered around
his new
essentials line of clothing or some [ __ ]
like that
throw on my essentials muscle t and a
mouth excuse me did you catch that his
essentials muscle tee
if you don't have that you're not
copping wins in the morning you get up
at 4 00 am but if you don't have an
essentials muscle t
you're losing baby how do these people
have like
so little self-awareness i just i don't
get it
my trousers i couldn't believe it i was
blown back into my chair
five brands it truly does sound
impossible and yet
thanks to the power of cold showers in
an early morning jog
jose is able to do it with ease but with
good time management
i'm actually able to balance everything
perfectly
now it's time for lunch eating clean
this is something that i live by i
preach about it all the time
health is wealth if you want to perform
right you got to feed your body with the
proper fuel
this is a truly riveting daily routine
he gets up he jogs he showers and he
eats
why the didn't i think of that if only i
had come up with these ingenious
solutions to wealth i could have five
brands by now god
and now frankly i'm just mad that he
shared the krabby patty secret formula
with the world
you see guys your time it's money which
means it's valuable this is why
i don't like to waste time and instead i
multitask so while i eat
i like to do my tedious task like
answering email what
is this man nay this god
he's able to eat and answer
emails oh jesus christ
that science said it couldn't be done
and yet jose's proved him wrong yet
again exactly
as he said in the beginning of the video
do what can't be
kicked off yesterday with what i can
today or
some profound garbage like that it's
incredible it's incredible
groundbreaking stuff
i looked into this because i got curious
this whole video is a promotional video
for his essential brand or whatever
this video alone he claims to have
generated a million dollars worth of
sales for his essential brand
now i'm no 24 year old five brand ceo
or anything but i i can say with a high
degree of certainty
you're not going to get enriched by
buying his essential muscle t's
that's just not gonna happen you're
immediately doing it wrong i like the
video is supposed to teach you how to
get wealthy and you're immediately
throwing
wealth away to make him wealthier you've
done the exact opposite of what you were
trying to do by watching this
motivational video
so if you bought essential muscle tees
thinking that you were going to get
jose's life
because you did that you're an idiot
now it's time for my evening workout my
brand image is everything
so keeping my body in shape is crucial
if that means hitting the weight room
six times a week
so be it two workouts in a single day
jose you've gone mad now i like to focus
on compound movements
being that i was a scrawny lanky kid
just a few years ago
these help me pack on about 30 pounds of
muscle now what that means for you is
that whether you're overweight or
scrawny yourself
you could do it too there's no excuse
well actually there is an excuse jose
not everyone is a super wealthy elite
douchebag
the gym membership's pretty expensive
for a lot of people and compound lifts
a lot of them require access to weights
that not everyone's going to be able to
find
for a cheap price for their own home gym
you know you need
bench press for example a squat rack
these are things that not everyone has
access to
unlike you and your mansion here that
you're probably renting
after the gym this is my time to unwind
more like behind
could you have found a tighter pair of
pants i feel like i can see your
hole through these things what are these
a size turbo small
was this just the smallest pair they had
available at baby gap
this is my favorite part i hop in the
car and go for a long drive
of course it's a lamborghini business is
like a chess game you always gotta be
three moves ahead of your competition
so whether that's analyzing the market
for new trends or a new business venture
going on these long drives allows me to
think creatively and freely
but only if you have a lamborghini if
you don't have a lamborghini you have no
right to be driving around on jose's
roads
also i don't really understand that how
the [ __ ] is driving around aimlessly
helping you and your business ventures
you are genuinely wasting time which is
one of the things you pledge never to do
it's not like you can get any work done
while you're on the road except make
idle calls every now and then at a
stoplight unless you're
texting while driving which you
shouldn't be but anyway this is a
genuine waste of time by all definitions
just
wildly aimlessly wandering the roads
doing nothing
that's like the first one i watched
because i was hunting
i was looking up his videos and i wanted
to watch something that i could like
you know relate to not relate to
like something that i knew would be
funny and then that was a good gateway
into his other videos
okay now let's do some speedrunning
[Music]